[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce pack consigne
est on est on est ravi de vous retrouver
et on est très pourquoi d'ailleurs pour
retrouver puisqu'il ya florence mercadé
bonjour bonjour patrice avocat au
barreau de versailles hall charlène
biennale du caire et jean baptiste
picasso c'est notre petit couple pour
aller vous très bien jean charles lajoie
ni bonjour bonjour éditeurs et justement
ya avec nous car pinault qui donne
auteur de romans policiers qui vit en
thaïlande où des têtes avec guodian de
thaïlande et vous ne raconterai comment
ça se passe voilà c'est quoi la période
actuellement c'est pas encore là des
chaleurs les moussons alors c'est pas
encore la mission mais c'est la période
où les températures montent et il comme
il pleut pas le soin on est on est sur
des périodes de chaleur avec de
l'humidité sens en sens inverse qui
libère un peu l'atmosphère soit très
bien les stéphanois sont bonjour bonjour
patrice on va bien vous êtes depuis que
je suis chez moi
jean à ces événements oui je m'en fous
d'assumer plus haut cours à l'université
de versailles et nous ne sommes ici avec
yen perdent au bonjour rien de verdu
vous êtes journaliste écrivain cette
journée sous vos échos et de brevets et
des enquêtes notamment sur les
traitements sur le ps d'être pro on en
parlera avec vous g
oubliez le week end au creusot bonjour
bonjour bonjour à tous
survient donc si tu me paraît d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant de ce qui se passe
pour les professions de santé pendant
encore le viseur du cul du courant 9e
cela peut-être commencer par je voudrais
votre impression générale c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps on nous a dit à notre
génération
bon vous avez pas vécu la guerre des
choses importantes
or quand on sait le fronton se
confrontent quand même qu'on a vécu la
chute du mur de berlin 11 septembre 2001
le terrorisme est aujourd'hui cet
épisode du gros navires us ce brave
monsieur c'est cette catastrophe c'est
pas pour il faut dire cette crise ça
dépend des les gens se serrent guerre et
des moussons le sont souvent différents
est ce que vous avez sous la pression
des autres de vivre quelque chose
d'historique
il veut commencer peut-être stéphane
lançant je suis pas quelque chose
d'historique par là la dimension
tout cela promet c'est vrai que ces
attaques et qui délivre deux camps mais
vide c'est quand même pas la première et
certainement pas la dernière
je déteste le président du chili sont
naturels qui fêtait le week-end une
bulle cette palette de l'histoire des
pandémies et c'est vrai que beaucoup de
gens manifestement la presse télé dit me
faire de sa villa vanille mort qui est
en effet géographiquement recul organisé
mais certainement pas la première mais
j'écris pour autant tiré par
l'impression de vivre après durablement
historique
d'accord on a vécu de loin l'ont certes
ans on a vécu les attentats islamistes
qu'on a vécu le temps choses et tant de
choses encore reste à vivre
pour autant l'histoire se fait au jour
le jour où tu sors tu l'as toujours
voilà sur cette année oui jean smart ad
oui si effectivement la pandémie est
quelque chose qui a déjà été connus en
revanche ce qui va être très inquiétant
c'est peut-être effectivement historique
c'est le crash économique arriver on
trouve on se retrouve effectivement sera
votre situation qui est d'après la
seconde guerre mondiale ça c'est
probablement ça d' historique par contre
dans cet événement peut-être aussi dans
son talent faire mondiale en ce qu'il
nous dit de façon libre du sentiment
qu'on avait tous c'est facile concernés
quelques mois les classes essien quels
que soient les faits nie toutefois le
meurtre
à mon sens face s'il devrait quand même
malheureusement on reste un peu
générationnel dans le sens on a le
sentiment que c'est coûteux l'écouté et
que les coûts jeunes enfants mais si on
va arriver à vivre coup franc sans moi
je crois que ces jeunes qui sont
atteintes sont parfois c'est pas le
morceau évoqué la grippe espagnole
est-ce qu'on peut comparer les messieurs
les deux épidémies
ah oui de mon point de vue on peut pas
s'empêcher de faire un parent est de
mettre les choses en perspective et
c'est vrai qu'il faut comme pour revenir
un petit mot aux chiffres et pour
prendre je sors un peu de recul
en 1918 l'humanité comptait moins de
deux milles hier individus qs
aujourd'hui nous sommes quatre fois plus
nombreux
nous sommes presque 8 milliards et les
dernières études montrent que l'épidémie
groupe espagnol as
hors effet 100 millions de morts à
l'époque soit 5 % la population mondiale
si on veut ramener ce chiffre
aujourd'hui ça faisait quatre cent
millions de morts
alors on parle le coronavirus a fait une
virée dans le monde c'était énorme c'est
bien évidemment terrible mais c'est sans
aucune commune mesure avec la vie des
stars alors le grenat virus et
heureusement de trois fois moins
mortelle que la grippe espagnole il dit
sophie toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises dans le monde entier font baisser
sa contagiosité alors et vous qu'il faut
garder il me faut relativiser appelé les
proportions
il faut se rappeler qu'en 2003 la
canicule a fait en france environ 2000
morts appelée de la grippe saisonnière
et environ 110 morts par an et puis
surtout il faudrait les revers d'esprit
que la barre des 73 m c'est en france
les cinéphiles du beau travail de
première nécessité alors on les a
laissés ouverts
les statistiques qui montrent que vous
faut si on prend aujourd'hui au mois
d'avril en a un peu moins demain on a un
peu plus de morts que l'année dernière
un peu moins qu'il ya deux ans donc
c'est vrai qu'on pourra utiliser mais
c'est que les maliens débattre convoite
avec tout le monde d'ailleurs ingres et
gnagna un départ qui se joue aujourd'hui
on voit bien des dents dans des pays
notamment les pays d'atta pour lesquels
peut-être la vie humaine est quelque
chose de très précieux et donc on a
choisi de poursuivre on voit bien dans
des pays du nord qui coûte dans les rues
de l'hyper ou bien vous avez pas mauvais
est ce que ça vous d'arrêter l'économie
est ce que pour vous il fallait
proximedia confinement et ne pas
continuer à vivre comme tous les jours
et sauvé l'économie
c'est un vrai débat et interviews oui
non on prend un peu le risque qu'un seul
qu'aucune critique vis-à-vis du
gouvernement qui prend lyon s'est pas
totalement les bonnes décisions et mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser la
question de savoir si c'est intelligent
de dire qu'on va mourir guéri en fait
parce que l'unc et tour des confiné tout
est arrêté
l'économie va mettre des mois si ce
n'est des années sans mais un nombre
incalculable de
d'autres prises vont faire faillite de
gens vont se retrouver au chômage on
voit ce qui se passe aux etats-unis on
voit ce qui se passe en france alors les
amortisseurs sociaux en france ça
fonctionne bien mais pour combien de
temps et voilà donc et ce confinement
plus posée à mon sens un vrai problème
c'est pas du tout scientifique mais là
on confine tout le monde on met tout
dans une boîte donc ok personne ne tombe
malade on va ouvrir la boîte tout le
monde va tomber malade donc c'est un peu
ce enfants parce que alors heureusement
on a quand même quelques quartiers de
france ou le confinement c'est juste un
mot visiblement pas compris ou la police
n'intervient pas de consigne ne pas
intervenir bon effectivement il ya des
gens qui vont quand même être contaminés
et c'est peut-être ça qui va nous sauver
est finalement mais voilà c'est
extrêmement inquiétant vous allez mourir
guéri moi c'est pas un truc qui
m'emballe voilà si vous voulez dans le
choix qui a eu qui a été fait c'est que
les projections son confinement aller
jusqu'à 500 morts en france
oui c'est à calais prendre cette
sociabilité et ça va on va voir en 2020
c'est ça me paraît inacceptable
une société comme la nôtre face au
danemark par exemple au danemark en
suède en hollande ou le confinement est
beaucoup moins ou un fort voire
inexistant avec simplement des gestes
barrières une responsabilisation une un
sens des responsabilités des habitants
qui peut être son sens où tout à fait
suffisant voilà donc là on peut se poser
la question et les médecins danois les
officiels danois des gouvernants danois
ne me paraissent pas être totalement
abruti donc ni les suédois donc voilà il
faut les aider
c'est la thèse ceci aussi bien dans des
pays différents
restez pas mention de tulle ont noté
qu'ils ont et moi moi moi ce qui me ce
qui me frappe
la façade originale c'est le fait qu'ils
valent
[Musique]
beaucoup de grands élus politiques une
compétition entre celui qui sera à la
fois le plus le plus démagogiques le
plus populistes les plus immédiats mais
la moitié tremble à l'idée que tous ces
gens là puissent un jour par votre
bureau ou poids lorsque l'on entend le
discours clair consiste à dire si si
nous avions été pour moi un moment pas
là enfin c'est c'est ça très risible si
les choses n'étaient pas aussi dans le
nombre de gens étonnants il ya un
perdant justement sur ce doute et vas y
que de vie qui sur ce débat est ce qu'un
débat dans la salle et vous pouvez
mettre ça les scientifiques est ce qu'il
ya des matches et les médecins c'est
justement celle que cette barre de 60%
tandis que c'est 60% de la population
est atteinte pour le virus ne l'a vu
dans play ces compressions ne connais
pas tellement à un bon c'est pas
tellement quelques élèves manquent de
gens qui sont atteints par le virus
[Applaudissements]
on a un petit problème de dire nous avec
vous attend non parce que là c'est
peut-être en mettant à des écouteurs
reconnecter avec vous la qualité c'est
de la merde de riz baptiste faynot bilan
deux morts dont un effectif et pour
rejoindre la question qui est économique
tellement moi j'ai vraiment le sentiment
de vivre un moment historique
donc par rapport à l'éducation du corona
virus
alors certes le lendemain ils sont
nombreux qui a été un challenge temps
qui courent on sait qu'ils n'ont réalisé
ce qui ne peut pas tout et que les
choses se déroulent de manière presque
instantanée ou en tout cas comme une
vague qui submerge en très peu de temps
l'ensemble de la planète et ça crée une
situation qui est asphyxiant puisque
nous avons un modèle qui aujourd'hui
n'est plus un modèle construit sur le
secteur primaire mais qui est construit
sur un modèle mondial c'est
qu'effectivement cette crise même
indépendamment du nombre de morts créer
une situation qui fait que le le monde
les états sont bouleversés ils sont mis
à l'épreuve face à cette situation dont
certains disent qu'il sera très très
difficile de dépasser
et je crois que nous serons plus là on
vit un moment qui est tout à fait inédit
est tout à fait à fait actuellement dans
le car le pineau justement puisque vous
et on parle de mondialisation vous êtes
en thaïlande et au concours alors quelle
est la situation là-bas d'ailleurs alors
en thaïlande
d'abord la nana la maladie semble selon
les chiffres que l'on a moins progressé
puisque on a plus de 2200 cas et moins
de 20 décès selon les chiffres officiels
il ya plusieurs raisons d'abord la la
proximité sociale qu'on attendait dans
nos pays occidentaux vos élus nous qui
sommes latins existe voit ici les gens
se serre pas la main
il n'ya pas d'embrassades ya une espèce
de distance qui seraient entre les
individus qui seraient que je pense que
le la maladie ces transports
ce que c'est trop speed moins facilement
il ya eu une bonne réaction aussi des
gouvernements les gens ont très vite se
sont mis à porter des masques que
j'emporte de toute façon des masques
pour la pollution et le monde sait bien
porter les masques et puis on a trouvé
absolument partout la produits
désinfectants pour les mains enfin bon
toutou tous ses accessoires
tous ces métiers aussi les petites mains
qui y viennent nettoyer les ascenseurs
tout ça qui font que la maladie se
propage mois donc d'un point de vue
personnes touchées il ya moins d'eau
moins de personnes touchées pour autant
le gouvernement prend prend des
décisions qui sont assez semblables à
celles qu'on constate en europe
c'est-à-dire fermeture des écoles ou à
mes gars ont étudié ici depuis quinze
jours
fermeture des aéroports fermeture des
frontières fermeture des bars des
restaurants et puis confinement couvre
feu de 22 heures à 2 heures du matin
voilà fondées ont déçu saison
sympathique vous mais vous avez été
victime avait été évité alors s'est
faite très difficile à certains je crois
que oui ma femme est repris dans les
derniers vols de france puisqu'elle
était en france elle est rentrée le 19
après ils ont fermé les frontières
locales auraient pas pu rentrer on sait
on s'est confiné en quittant bangkok au
bord de la mer et elle a très vite
souffert de ce qui paraît être les
symptômes c'est à dire montée de fièvre
perte de l'ouïe l'odorat
c'est pousser et dans la foulée moi j'ai
eu trois jours de grosse fatigue mal aux
reins et puis aussi sur les fourreaux
maintenant comme on n'a pas été testée
maintenant on va mieux maintenant est ce
qu'on a vraiment été touchée je pense
que c'est les tests qui nous le dirons
plus tard pour l'instant on a évité
d'aller se mélanger à dans les hôpitaux
parce que c'était pas c'était pas
l'urgence on a priori on est passé au
travers ce qui nous intéresse pas par
contre si pouvoir se tester le tweet
possible pour savoir si on les porteurs
ou ou si on est ministre
mais alors parce que certains médecins
commencent à dire c'est pas sûr parce
qu'on a eu ce virus qu'on soit
totalement immunisés c'est un des débats
alors il ya un grand débat n'est qu'un
lieu actuellement sur qu'on peut résumer
ici
le pistage dépistage c'est à dire que
pour sortir de de confinement il est
probable qu'on va essayer de savoir sur
la base du volontariat semble-t-il
où seront les gens qui sont atteints de
colite 19 pour puisse les tracés qu'on
puisse prévenir ceux qui les côtoient
etc
ça donne évidemment due à un débat sur
est-ce qu'on va a tenté à nos libertés
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce débat
moi je suis complètement d'accord aux
clients un tracking numérique
on voit que dans les pays comme taiwan
la corée du sud ou singapour ils ont
réussi à juguler vraiment la prévention
d'infections avec des tests systématiser
avec un trafic digital en israël aussi
ils ont mis en point des algorithmes qui
permettent de suivre de prévenir les
gens et on voit que c'est très efficace
et finalement je vous c'est un faux
débat puisque nos libertés aujourd'hui
elles sont complètement réduite
on est confiné chez nous on peut même
plus faire une émission tous ensemble
donc la question des libertés finalement
allé déjà été tranchée et je crois qu'on
n'en est plus à se poser la question
d'un train inconnu mais ça peut paraître
un indépendant
derrière garde mais mon terminal je
pense qu'il faut faire je pense que
stéphane ans on sera probablement
d'accord en tant que juriste là dessus
il faut faire un équilibre entre la
protection de la santé publique qui est
tout à fait légitime et une atteinte à
nos libertés individuelles notamment je
pense à ces histoires de trafic ce qui a
été fait en corée du sud ou en chine
et comme extrêmement attristé alors que
ce sur quoi réfléchir gouvernement
dépassiez intrusif que cela puisque ça
va rester anonyme et on va avoir
finalement des gens qui vont se croiser
pendant un certain temps il y aura un
moment donné un message qui va être
donnée pour dire voilà vous avez tous
les deux vous avez croisé des gens avec
le même logiciel la même application
et ce pourrait être cette personne soit
contaminée et donc il faut il faut se
préserver préserver les autres mais on
va sur de l'anonymat après ceux dont il
faudra être à sucre et la traçabilité
des données qui se court puisque ont
collecté est d'abord faudrait savoir si
oui ou non est ce que comme on est sur
la base du volontariat une vieille
rating de volontaires pour le faire
parce que si un peu de voix confère sa
sert pas à grand chose
c'est quand même un nom est-ce qu'il
faut pas tout à fait carrément
trompeuses mesure le plus plus dissuasif
entre sans vraiment ceux qui ont la
maladie en essayant de faire une étable
le politique préventive
je souhaite bien du plaisir aux gens qui
vont aller dans certains coins de france
pour expliquer qu'il faut de pister les
téléphones qu'il faut traquer les trucs
ça va être rock n roll après est-ce
qu'il suffit que 70% de la population
accepte et si ça marche sera merveilleux
si tout ça ne fonctionne que si 100 %
des gens adhèrent alors là c'est un peu
que c'est même pas la peine d'y songer
une seule seconde on sait très bien je
veux dire il ya des quartiers où la
police ne va pas on les voit très mal y
aller en dix ans maintenant
donnez-nous votre portable on va les
pistes et on va savoir où vous allez
livrer ce que vous devez livrer enfin
donc ça me paraît totalement incohérent
donc c'est une question de proportion au
fait qui c'est ce que j'aimerais qu'on
me conduisent des six
70% la population accepte ça fonctionne
tant mieux ajouter quelque chose c'est
que je crois que le débat est
entièrement fausse et à partir du moment
où on a installé une loi sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
on essaye de nous expliquer que
l'application des libertés l'application
hongrois demande est totalement mise en
sous couvert étant donné qu à cet
impératif de santé publique qui paraît
plus important et je crois que ça fait
d'ailleurs partie de notre corpus
constitutionnelle de notre manière de
percevoir la chance d'habiter la santé
humaine sont placés normalement parmi
les maires de nos libertés donc je crois
on a tendance à assez bien comprendre
que nos libertés individuelles soit
diminué par rapport à cet impératif de
lutter contre l'épidémie
donc moi je ne vois pas en quoi on fait
un débat par rapport à nos libertés
individuelles sachant qu elles sont
quand même déjà l'unité et que c'est le
principe de cette mise en état d'urgence
sanitaire donc mois après sur le traçage
et l'anonymat j'ai le sentiment qu'on
manque de courage politique pour aller
plus loin parce que soit on choisit la
solution coréenne et humide et on y va
obligatoirement et sans anonymat et on
fait chacun une un don à la science mais
pour quelque chose qui est un peu plus
important que nous que ça c'est la santé
soit on considère qu'il faut quand même
très protégé des libertés individuelles
mais je crains alors à quand on l'a
compris de l'application de son but
suprême c'est à dire d'essayer de nous
sauver tous est de mieux connaître ce
virus aussi moi je te pète d'accord avec
ce fait d'accord avec vous si ce n'est
qu' il faut être absolument certains que
ces mesures qui sont prises pour
restreindre nos libertés individuelles
ne le sont que provisoirement et on sait
très bien et on le voit par rapport aux
mesures qui ont été prises dans le cadre
de l'urgence au regard des attentats
terroristes
ce ne sont pas des mesures qui ont été
toutes mises entre parenthèses il y en a
qui existe encore aujourd'hui il faut
les deux menaces et les deux régimes
juridiques non mais non mais dans ces
rien parce que ce n'est pas le premier
virus que l'on va avoir c'est ce n'est
pas le dernier
et si on dit bah écoutez il faut quand
même qu'on se préserve contre les virus
à venir parce qu'on est en train de nous
expliquer qui aura peut-être une
deuxième bague en octobre et pourquoi
pas en 2021
à ce moment là c'est la même chose que
pour le terrorisme c'est qu'il va
falloir que c'est ces mesures perçues
perdure et on les aura toujours de quoi
nos libertés individuelles la faudra
mettre une sacrée pas de succès c'est
juste ça qui me pose problème
stéphane mensonge je vais réciter moment
bon philosophe préféré s'interdit tout
pouvoir et entraîné au fond vers
l'autoritarisme et que c'est des
séquences comme celle là m'ont montré ou
font que démocratie ou pas de démocratie
tous les pouvoirs ont envie d'être
autoritaire et que cette séquence à
faciliter cet autoritarisme qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
rassurez-nous patrice mensuel avait dit
avant un dernier amusé des attentes au
titre ' matériels mais moi je je pense
qu'en tout état cause où on est on est
sous l'empiré d'une légalité crise
maintenant du l'égalité particulière des
modalités particulières d'applications
certaines règles de droit mais le droit
n'est jamais absent les libertés ne sont
jamais totalement remis
il ya encore et fort heureusement dans
notre ordre juridique une ce mécanisme
de l'égalité de crise qui permet qu en
tout état cause ultime mans on doit
toujours se poser cette question du
respect des droits et libertés
fondamentaux même s'il sait qu'il était
subi c'est évidemment des restrictions
tout à fait exceptionnelle et
heureusement à rejoindre le rang sur le
l'importance du caractère exceptionnel
et temporaire que c'est à pain et la
question de l'équilibré des droits et
libertés doit toujours
se poser ce qui évidemment ventoux
complexe le conseil d'état fonctionne
encore le conseil constutionnel si nos
juridictions championnat en mode dégradé
mais ça fonctionne pas encore le droit
produit fort heureusement encore ses
effets donc ça serait tellement plus
simple si on faisait passer un impératif
de manière absolue par rapport aux
autres mais on est dans un état droit
dans une démocratie et les choses sont
forcément beaucoup plus compliquées
qu'elles peuvent l'être
jean baptiste du caire mais
effectivement je crois que le tracking
et peut fonctionner que s'il y avait
rendu obligatoire la question
effectivement de les poser est celle de
savoir si l'on peut imposer la collecte
de données sans obtenir le contrepoint
des personnes à charlene a très bien
expliqué le débat au plan
constitutionnel mais ce débat a
également été tranché si je puis dire au
plan du droit gagnant rapport européenne
puisque en matière de données
personnelles
il ya le règlement général à la
protection des données qui exprime en
régie ce qui est permis ou interdit de
faire saisissant des données et il y a
des stipulations justement des
dispositions par l'entente de règlement
qui prévoit expressément que en cas de
crise en termes de sécurité publique
même salutaire
il est possible de faire un traitement
des données sans obtenir le retrait du
consentement des personnes et ce qui me
gêne jeu face à cette situation c'est
que la cnil s'est prononcé hier par la
voix des lois dans un sens défavorable à
l'usagé cracking de passants dilatoire
ils sont nos gouvernants ont sans doute
pas dans une logique il n'est pas seul
hic la courage politique de saisie mais
d'une peur juridique justement notamment
à l'aide qui est exprimé par par la cnil
et je crois que c'est dommage parce que
nos positions ce que le droit permet de
collecter les données de fer aux à ce
titre acquis de façon de dire alors on a
récupéré yann verre d'eau pardon je vous
donne ma parole mais quatre geste juste
pour dire qu'on a récupéré on va parler
dans un assaut de de l'état ou à louer
sont donnés des traitements
allez-y par ben oui moi je vais faire
remarquer quand même qu'on est face à
une situation qui est absurde parce que
si on regarde bien on réagit face à
cette crise avec les mêmes moyens que en
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une danse où
on est on a on utilise absolument pas
les moyens technologiques ils sont à
notre disposition on est dans une
démarche qui est purement empirique qui
consiste à réutiliser des vieilles
recettes que sont le confinement les
mesures barrières etc
au lieu de se projeter dans une vision
beaucoup plus rationnel scientifique et
d'utiliser les moyens qui sont les
nôtres aujourd'hui c'était le dépistage
systématique de mettre en place vraiment
une politique de santé global lancé
replier sur deux manières de faire et
justement c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que lorsque j'ai étudié les
parallèles entre la grippe espagnole et
la crise d'aujourd'hui
en fait on se rend compte que notre
système de santé il est complètement le
fruit de la grippe espagnole
il faut bien comprendre que les loups
msa exemple les prémices de l oms ont
été constitués à la suite de la dette
espagnole et on est revenus à nos vieux
archaïsme repli sur soi confinement au
lieu justement d'essayer de se projeter
dans quelque chose de moderne et devait
la crise par le haut et c'est en ça que
je pense que le trafic digital est une
des solutions mais n'est pas la seule
mais teckel sa langue natale espère
arrêter quoi la sortie par le haut salat
été de multiplier les tests
c'est ce qu'ont fait les pays sacrifiés
à 7,6 et l'anoci
c'est de mettre en place vraiment une
politique de santé
je trouve dingue par exemple qu'on est
critiqués le professeur out pour avoir
fait du dépistage plus systématique à
marseille alors après c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un mélange d'empirisme et
d'essayer de trouver des solutions
mais voilà il faut sortir de nos vieux
réflexes
parce que justement la folie comme le
design stein c'est de refaire la même
chose
résultats différents essais sont en
train de faire aujourd'hui on est en
train de reproduire finalement en
occident ce qu'on a fait il ya cent ans
et on espère avoir un résultat différent
bien sûr qu'on va avoir un cric crac et
polémiques énorme si on n'essaie pas de
trouver des solutions innovantes
salariés verre d'eau si on vous entend
maintenant on va voir je changeais
d'ordinateur vous avez fait un très bon
article sur les sites ce qu'on appelle
des ses discours il c'est à dire le test
au fond des traitements les résultats
devaient être publiés n'ont pas été on a
l'impression qu'à aussi et autres
retards dans la façon dont ils sentent
que des difficultés ou démarrage de cet
essai qui mise puisque les premiers
résultats s'étaient des résultats tout à
fait préliminaires des premiers
résultats étaient annoncées pour le
week-end du 4-5 avril et finalement ça a
été le black out
bon ceci dit il faut quand même remettre
les choses en perspective cet essai king
qui est donc européens premiers 200
patients au niveau européen pour lui
sans empreinte a été montée vraiment en
un temps record c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure je ne sais pas s'il
m'avait entendue mais je parlais de la
crainte que la très grande réactivité de
la recherche et notamment de la
recherche clinique qui a subi une
accélération une accélération de son
rythme naturel toutes les les procédures
les types colle les autorisations comité
d'éthique pour monter un essai clinique
qui en temps normal était des processus
qui promet plusieurs mois là on était
réduit à quelques jours donc il ya
vraiment une accélération très fort du
talent cela dit cet essai clinique qui
donc vise à pester 4-4-2 traitement
contre 2,19
n'a pas livré les premiers résultats
comme attendu et ces derniers jours
commence à d'air qui fonctionne et qui
patronne qui pilote les cinq minutes
sachez que l'on disait que ses résultats
seraient dévoilés la fin de mois feindre
une avec avec une chose qu'on trouve un
traitement façon pas pareil pour
préparer la loi en effet trois autres
chacune plutôt son véhicule hydroxy que
du fait partie des 4 méga traitement qui
ont testé dans le cadre de discovery
s'était pas le coeur des bars d'ailleurs
ils ont rajouté après un peu sous la
pression des résultats annoncées à
marseille par didier raoult
les trois autres sont des antiviraux
développé initialement d'ailleurs
d'autres médicaments c'est ça qui pour
d'autres maladies parmi ces tas qui ait
un sens de constater c'est qu'en fait
ces médicaments sont des cds
repositionnement de médicaments
existants
ils ont été développés pour l'un pour
ebola l'autre c'est des antirétroviraux
contre le vih et l'identique eurokin
qu'il est donc un antipaludéen dont il
s'agit de repositionner des médicaments
auditionné comme ils disent là mais
qu'elles voudront
quand vous puisque vous êtes le tout
dans cette position parfois les de la
bombe faut changer un peu les des
procédures est-ce que là aussi pour le
le test des débuts des traitements par
exemple il faudrait aller plus vite
qu'on ne voit d'habitude par exemple que
ferrat août
marseille est en effet il faut il faut
savoir aussi raison garder c'est vrai
que c'est très difficile pour un pouvoir
politique de valider un médicament qui
n'a pas été développée pour cet usage
et donc je comprend à la fois
l'engouement du professeur à holt et je
comprends aussi
les atermoiements du gouvernement au
sujet de la chloroquine et diderot xi
chloroquine parce qu'on peut pas non
plus diffuser un médicament en dehors de
son autorisation de mise sur le marché
sans avoir quelques quelques quelques
tests et quelques rues recul là par
exemple je lisais que dans certains pays
du nord il allait arrêter de prescrire
de la chloroquine et de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine parce qu'ils étaient face à
de nouveaux effets secondaires qui
n'était pas prévu initialement
donc il faut aussi savoir raison garder
et garder sur sa rationalité et c'est
très bien que la clause qui nous soient
testés dans des essais cliniques comme
discovery
mais ces voix-là cc il faut c'est très
dur de garder un juste milieu dans une
crise comme celle ci doit donc ça c'est
très beau il ya aussi le problème un
problème qu'est à 500cc suis des masques
puisque pendant très longtemps on nous a
dit ça sert à rien et aujourd'hui on de
10 pratiquement c'est obligatoire sauf
que personne ne trouve si on n'est pas
un cent des professions de santé à part
mustapha larfaoui qui les pharmacies que
peu de voix au noir dès qu'ils soient
démasqués défaut au basket artisanaux
voit bien que c'est quand même un peu
bidon
non il ya un effet pervers qui est
dénoncé par les des médecins danois et
tous les médecins indiquent qu'il dit
parce que le masque pas très bien porter
pas très bien utiliser qui bail qui lie
un peu sur les côtés ça va rassurer les
gens qui vont se dire bah ça va c'est
bon on a un masque on sera pas contaminé
on contaminent pas les gens suppression
des gestes-barrières suppression de
l'attention qu'on porte à cette
propagation du virus et qu'en fait le le
masque pour être pire que l'absence de
masques alors c'est la position des
danois des suédois qui paraît pas
complètement idiote alors c'est vrai que
là on est aussi dans une dans un moment
où une fois que la vague
a saisi l'opinion publique plus personne
ne peut décemment dire le master parce
que ça y est le la france opté pour le
masque et n'importe quel scientifique
pourrait dire quoi que ce soit d'autre
maintenant la france veut des masques
donc la france aura des masques mais la
dictée libre et si c'est juste une
remarque de bon sens on est probablement
un peu mieux protégés avec un masque ce
contrat
oui mais il faut faire le distinguo il
faut faire le distinguo parce que les
masques chirurgicaux aux convois vrai
suisse à son image c'est qu'ils sont
censés protéger l'autre et ça me fait
vraiment contrairement aux masques ffp2
qui sont les masques bec de canard qui
sont faits pour se protéger soi même et
donc l'intérêt des masques chirurgicaux
c'est que dans un espace clos en
particulier si tout le monde porte un
masque
forcément il ya une protection mutuelle
et le risque de contamination baissent
drastiquement
mais je veux attirer l'attention sur un
point c'est que justement dans une pièce
s'il a dit porter de masque et qu'un
seul n'emporte pas et que celui ci est
contaminée qu'il éternue
il va contaminer les autres c'est parce
que chirurgicaux ne protège pas pour
nous mêmes il protège l'autre donc à mon
sens bien sûr qu'il faut des masques et
est une aberration que la france est
complètement dissous son stock de
masques depuis lé 2013 dont point de vue
c'est quand même la question se pose
pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait des dons de
masques à la chine et à l'iran on a
envoyé 17 tonnes de matériel à la chine
alors qu'on savait que nos stocks
étaient à 0 donc il ya quand même les
questions qui se posent et on a vu aussi
il ya eu d'abord des politiques très
différentes
là dessus et calvino comment ça se passe
en thaïlande et les gens portent le
masque des choses comme ça alors un en
fait déjà le masque est quand même assez
culturel en thaïlande
beaucoup de gens portent le masque ne
serait que parce que bon quand on a une
pollution importante et donc le masque
est quelque chose qui est déjà qui est
déjà dans les moeurs
donc les gens leur dire de porter un peu
plus le masque ça secret ça s'est fait
tout de suite et ça s'est fait
naturellement
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que de 2
du point de vue là de la thaïlande quand
on regarde le débat encore de masques
par port de masque en fait la réponse
qu'on lisait dans les journaux c'était
mais finalement je je ne transmet pas si
j'ai un masque mais je peux le recevoir
et puisque je peux le recevoir ça sert à
rien de porter mais je pense que c'est
une vision qui est qui et qui n'est pas
bonne je veux dire à partir du moment où
je peux moi protéger l'autre eh bien je
porte le masque puisqu'il ya une latence
entre le moment où je sais que je suis
affecté et le moment où je je je vais
pouvoir le transmettre
il ya au moins 48 heures ou si je porte
le masque je suis peut-être affectée et
jaune je ne vais pas contaminer l'autre
donc si tout content de ce qui est
important c'est de la contaminer l'autre
tout le monde sont au protège vraiment
rire de nous rejoindre bon journaliste
au figaro va on va vous avez une enquête
justement on va en parler un petit peu
tout à l'heure parce que ça fait partie
des conséquences économiques sur le
tourisme et bah comment se porte le
tourisme actuellement évidemment mal
mais que font les professionnels du
tourisme et et comment il pense qu'elle
est d'aider les choses ont évolué on va
parler d'un petit moment avec août
j'ai quand même qu'on voit bienne 1
justement sur une économie par exemple
jean charles lajoie ni vous êtes éditeur
voilà vous êtes parti tu période
extrêmement compliqué pour le premier on
a en a effectivement perdu depuis le
depuis le 15 mars par depuis la date du
début du confinement et la fermeture des
librairies nous à notre maison d'édition
mais comme tous les éditeurs les plus
gros les plus petits 95 % du chiffre
d'affaires de 95 % du chiffre d'affaires
se fait dans des librairies qui sont
fermés alors il en reste il peut dans
les maisons de la presse font un rayon
livres dans quelques grandes surfaces
qui ont également rayon libre il ya
heureusement ça va plaire aux libraires
mais amazon et la fnac qui ont quelques
stocks et qui permettent quand même de
faire circuler quelques lignes mais 90%
du chiffre d'affaires s'en est allé ça
c'est déjà le drame absolu parce que une
boîte plus de chiffre d'affaires c'est
quand même extrêmement gênant
et puis le redémarrage qui est bon
tu peux pas dans secret des dieux mais
on peut peut-être imaginer pour le
d'environ de la mi mai vincee traduire
par un embouteillage absolument dément
non mais progressif progresser avec
megal qui posait aux ministres et enfin
en tout cas l'envers de plan sur la
comète mais quelle que soit la date à la
date du redémarrage
ça va être un embouteillage alors là je
veux pas rentrer dans des considérations
très technique mais chaque année en
france à 70 milles livres qui sont
publiés soixante dix mille nouveaux
livres donc deux mois d'arrêt total mars
avril et 15 jours du mois de mai ça fait
plus de 15000 à 20000 livres qui n'ont
pas été distribués donc quand ça va
redémarrer logistiquement il est
impossible pour les distributeurs quelle
que soit leur taille de distribuer
autant le dire est impossible évidemment
pour les libraires d'accueillir autant
le niveau
s'ajoutent à ça le fait et la télé car
le pineau va se mettre à pleurer
mais qu'est ce que c'est le roi de la
dédicace mais que toutes les dédicaces
est ce que les dédicaces doit être
autorisée il a quel moment délicat alors
les vallées alors de retenir et c'est
alors justement puisqu'on parle de
livres je profite pour on a deux livres
peut-être vous pouvez conseillez celui
diane verdu qui s'appelle une zone où le
barrage sans mémoire et le faux le
journal d'un médecin qui se rencontrer
quelqu'un qui a perdu totalement les
mémoires ça se passe en angleterre à la
fin du 19e siècle
c'est ça rien à voir que comme 19,6 et
1,5 et 2,0 toute sa peine de mort ou le
bas rhin sans mémoire c'est aux éditions
du rocher
voilà on voit la couverture là et puis
il ya le sicilien où carla présenté peu
après qu'un peu en parler mais mary
surtout très contente que le sicilien
vient d'avoir le prix du polar des
libraires des petits mots des libraires
qui est un prix décerné par notamment
fin à l'initiative de 40 grosses
librairies indépendantes françaises et
qui décerne à prix est extrêmement
important et je félicite car mais on est
très content et très fier qu'il est
qu'il ait eu ce prix mais il peut parler
de son livre bien mieux que moi
avant le sicilien c'est le deuxième opus
d'une trilogie
j'ai commencé en 2010 ce qui constitue
en trois ans dépendantes sur trois
décennies les des années 80 les années
90 et le prochain qui paraîtra les
années 2000 inquiétant à travers une
intrigue policière de faire une photo
sociétal sur ces trois décennies cela
les années 90 on est plus sur la
thématique malheureusement de 10 sites à
d'un point de vue sociétal et qui
oscille après la chute du mur de berlin
de l'a29 delaveau du bouleversant les
modes et des mafias avec l'arrivée des
machines baissent alors je suis quand
même que malgré la fermeture des
librairies certaines livre qui a aussi
toujours les livres numériques
évidemment oppose progrès on peut quand
même lire et où il faut lire pendant
sept heures cette quête de 2019
je reviens à redon ont parlé de la
situation des des éditeurs
michael nombreux jours par exemple les
portistes disons il faut quoi la vie
ferment leur cabinet vous avez une
roulette et ben écoutez oui
effectivement en fait nous nous avons un
énorme problème c'est que lorsque l'on
soigne un patient avec des instruments
qui tourne à 300 mille tours minutes ça
crée un brouillard on a démontré que
saigner particules
ces micro gouttelettes pouvait rester en
suspension dans l'air pendant des heures
et donc tous les cabinets dentaires sont
fermés depuis le 16 mars sur ordre de
notre conseil de l'ordre est d'ailleurs
j'attire l'attention des patients j'ai
entendu qu'il y avait encore quelques
cadeaux mais qu'il était ouvert en toute
illégalité et c'est très grave parce
qu'ils sont pas couverts par leur
assurance on ne sait pas s'ils ont les
conditions pour soigner dans des
conditions correctes
vraiment ils sont hors la loi et je
tiens à le dire aux téléspectateurs
il ne faut pas aller dans les cabinets
qui seront ouverts illégalement
quant à l'aide d'urgence alors voilà
garde
en fait tous les dentistes nous ne
sommes pas en vacances nous sommes tous
quelque part de garde donc tous les
patients qui ont besoin de conseils qui
sont en urgence qu'on des couleurs
doivent d'abord contacté leur chirurgien
dentiste qui doit être joignable soit
par téléphone soit par mail
il va réaliser un premier filtre et si
vraiment il y avait besoin d'un soin en
urgence à ce moment là il va leur donner
le numéro de la régulation
il est aussi un numéro national que je
pourrais donner et en cas vraiment
d'urgence qui nécessite un soin il y
avait cabinet de garde qui sont équipés
par le conseil de l'ordre et qui vont
pouvoir réaliser des soins en urgence
avec des des équipements spécifiques et
dans des conditions d'asepsie optimale
mercredi la justice
comment ça se passe eh ben ça se passe
pas sauf dans les affaires pénales
d'urgence où les libertés sont mis en
cause donc s'assurera sur ces
thématiques la justice fonctionne elle
fonctionne sur les problématiques aussi
deux pas de la famille parce qu'il ya
des les cas extrêmement douloureux du
chef déconfite manqué personne qui était
en procédure de divorce et qui n'étaient
pas qu'ils vivaient toujours sous le
même toit
même des conflits voire des violences
conjugales et donc se renferme sur moi
voilà qui deviennent très très grave
donc là la justice peut être saisie
d'urgente alors le seul problème c'est
s'est donc joint au cabinet on traite un
dossier où la femme sollicite paris lui
et vous avez pas pu m'en acheter de
violence d'ivresse et folie donc à la
saisie on a saisi le juge aux affaires
familiales pour que le mari puisse
quitter le domicile est retourné chez sa
maman
mais ça pose problème sur les histoires
de confinement et il va falloir qu'il y
ait des mesures particulières qui soit
parce qu'ils quittent le domicile
et puis cette confiné ailleurs ses fans
et baptiste et à mesure mais de
l'université ça c'est fermé c'est celle
des cours par pincement sont fermés mais
non on travaille on fait des courants
lions fait les conférences audio donc on
on a assez de temps pour aller cueillir
les fraises d'accord alors maritime
bonjour je m'appelle cette journée
historique
il vous a fait une enquête justement il
ya un des secteurs évidemment qu'être
extrêmement touché celui du tourisme
oui totalement comme on peut s'en douter
le secteur du tourisme va très mal
actuellement pour vous donner une idée
un peu chiffrées environ 90% des 35
mille salariés du secteur des
entreprises du voyage seraient concernés
par des mesures de chômage partiel ce
qui est un peu paradoxal par ailleurs
parce que c'est un moment il ya
énormément de travail notamment pour les
agents de voyages qui sont en première
ligne avec les rapatriements de français
qui étaient bloqués à l'étranger ces
dernières semaines la situation est
presque de réguler donc c'est un moment
très compliqué sachant qu'en parallèle
ils doivent aussi ses agents de voyages
gérer l'après crise non pour sauver ce
pc dont on voit bien d'ailleurs les
compagnies aériennes sauf parmi les pays
qui devraient toucher il ya plus
pratiquement plus d'avions dans le ciel
ce qui vaut pour la pollution mais nous
avons pour leurs affaires
les opa en vacances on est confiné et
aux rousses est-ce qu'on a une idée de
du moment alors j'aime parler de tout
mais est ce que par exemple des gens se
posent la question est-ce qu'il faut que
je retienne pour les vacances au mois
d'août ou mois de juillet ce que ça
c'est bien il ya une petite reprise
comme ça dit alors oui c'est un peu un
peu compliqué de faire des prévisions on
aimerait que ça reprenne pour les
vacances d'été
c'est peut-être un peu optimiste j'ai eu
en ligne
conquis et le pdg d'asia voyage qui lui
me disait me signifier avoir déjà des
réservations pour l'automne
ça tombe octobre notamment pour les
destinations comme le japon alors il est
dans le département évidemment il ya
versailles ou en terre et il est dans le
château le château de versailles taux
des bons du mans les plus visités de
france la chimie aux personnes ça ça
pose en effet d'aider des problèmes
alors ils vont s'en sortir évidemment
puisqu'elle ne le montrent pas retenir
après mais ça pose en effet un ça va
fm si tous ces monuments qui font des
plus visités france qu'il faut de la
france d'ailleurs le premier pays en
matière de tourisme
ça pose d'évidents problèmes de dribble
de ski oui c'est un gros gros plein
d'eau versailles est fermé depuis le 13
mars comme alors comme tous les
monuments aigner comprennent la galerie
des carrosses et fermer les volets
chateaubriand pareil on n'est pas calé
perdant reste ouvert enfin c'est pas un
prétexte pour aller faire un jogging
c'est déjà ça évidemment c'est une perte
économique énorme donc pour versailles
j'ai pas j'ai pas de chiffres précis à
l'échelle de la france ce qui a été
avancé par par jean-baptiste lemoyne le
secrétaire d'état au tourisme
ce serait une perte de 40 milliards
d'euros par trimestre mieux à la baisse
de fréquentation touristique donc c'est
assez dramatique encore plus pour des
monuments comme marseille
alors ça pose un vrai problème
d'ailleurs parce que mon sens il y avait
une tribune par exemple de mon amour
dans libération qui dit zimbra il faut
il faut que les tarés interviennent il
faut renationaliser les i fo etc
sauf que on va se retrouver quand même
avec un état extrêmement endettée
beaucoup plus endetté qu'il ne l'est est
ce que justement cette heure cet
endettement de l'état n'a pas entraîné
une certaine faiblesse et i contre cas
au fond le désir de réintervention
d'état j'ai compris même s'il n'est pas
très clair ce que j'ai dit
poser la question c'est un peu à tout le
monde moi un désir d'état n'est pas ce
qui sera un peu faible parce qu'il sera
surendettés en tout cas toute l'humanité
tutoie que béni des gilet jaune ou en
critiquer sans arrêt le talent et à
c'était c'était le c'était l'horreur
c'était l'enfer et c est là maintenant
tout le monde semble bien content
d'avoir cet état qui qui est un des
mises qui soutient qui protège et là
effectivement comme le disait sylvain
tesson il semble qu'on ait un peu moins
envie de brûler les ronds-points en soi
même et donc on ne peut que s'en réjouir
il ya beaucoup de temps en temps des
effets positifs
à chaque catastrophe l'endettement il se
mesure essentiellement aujourd'hui au
niveau européen on y voit deux euros des
pays de la zone euro et j'ai
l'impression que la bce va être
forcément obligé d'aider les états à
continuer à investir dans leurs
économies et peut-être à fermer les yeux
ni endettement excessif
donc moi j'ai plutôt tendance à penser
que les débats qu'on a eu du bon niveau
de déficit et niveau d'endettement qui
était censé nous paralyser pour à celle
économiquement vont finalement eux mêmes
être mis de côté et j'ai le sentiment
qu'on sera peut-être aidé en tout cas
dans cette sortie de crise est à mon
sens est ici c'est à ce moment là qu'on
mesure à l'efficace prix du m christine
lagarde était interviewé ce matin sur
france inter
et je pense que l'état la faiblesse de
l'état dépendra effectivement comme
médiane charlène de l'art de la
réactivité de la bce et largesses de la
bce et du la durée de remboursement des
prêts qui pourraient être alloués à
l'état elle disait clairement ce matin
que le remboursement des dettes
vis-à-vis de la bce se ferait mais sur
de très longues années donc on a parlé
un moment 20 ans 30 ans tour rembourser
la dette et donc si on à niveau européen
et j'espère que les ministres des
affaires étrangères vont pouvoir se
mettre d'accord
d'ici peu si on a un accord sur des
prêts sur des remboursements extrêmement
lointain l'etat sera fort et l'état ne
sera pas fait il est très intéressante
c'est celle des coraux navarre où
justement il pose la question de savoir
si on pourra rendre des titres comme
deux d'être commun à tous les états de
l'union et on voit qu'on est là que ray
nord-sud qui est en train de se recréer
justement sur les états les moins
endettés et des états en meilleure santé
moi je crois que l'union européenne en
tout cas l'om doit vraiment arriver à
vite se sortir de cette division entre
ceux qui sont plus simples et ceux qui
le sont moins
parce que sans ça c'est le système de la
monnaie unique y voit ça n'est pas loin
d'une crise latente et encadrement du
dernier krach financier
c'était la même chose justement bat
stéphane minson pas le propos d'avant et
d'après dans cette crise
beaucoup de gens disent le canton va
sortir ça sera plus jamais comme avant
et c est ce que vous y croyez ça reste
vraiment ça va changer des mentalités ou
est ce que finalement on va pouvoir ou à
vouloir retrouver la vie d'avant c'est
une tendance quasi quasi naturel de
vouloir retrouver la vie d'adam dans ce
qu'elles avaient de meilleur
mais je ne crois pas non plus que cette
cette situation de crise est assimilable
à un grand soir loi des bouleversements
qui doivent totalement éradiqué le
système qui est le nôtre c'est-à-dire un
système libéral et tant sur le plan
économique que sur tout autre plan
politique libérale au sens en france
henri à colbert piste du terme moi je je
je vois dans la situation française
depuis des années on nous le rend quel
que soit le gouvernement
l'existence d'un état qui reste un état
fort
en tout cas par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres états occidentaux
donc je ne crois pas que le
bouleversement ira jusqu'à 1 bouleversé
est ce ce système mais en tout cas il y
aura des aspects sur lesquels il va
falloir réfléchir évidemment sur la
prévention d'un certain nombre d evry
des îles et sert à la reconstitution de
stocks la relocalisation de la
production d'un certain nombre de
produits je pense à des médicaments etc
je suis pas du tout d'ailleurs je ne
peux plus le crois pas une seconde que
une relation quasi totale comme la
préconisent montebourg soit une
souhaitable je resterai aussi pour
rejoindre notre débat de tout à l'heure
que les droits et libertés reprendront
aussi l'ensemble de leurs de leurs
effets je voulais un point moi qui me
semble qu'il semble acquis c'est qu'on
ne pourra jamais prévoir l'imprévisible
même si on te dira cette pandémie était
quelque part un moment donné peut être
prévisible on se pose aussi ce genre de
questions dans tout ce qui concerne la
sûreté nucléaire depuis des années où on
essaie de prévoir l'imprévisible
pour autant on y arrivera yann verre
d'eau ou est-ce que dans le monde des
milieux scientifiques on pense qu'il va
falloir ben justement changer les
priorités peut être peut être
relocalisée en effet la fabrication de
médicaments
oui ça comme je le disais tout à l'heure
mais ça fait partie des choses je sais
pas si vous n'avez entendu ou pas il est
clair que que cette cette crise montre
quand même à révéler une certaine
fragilité de notre modèle de
développement et notamment sur 7
cette question alors relocaliser une
parole de relocaliser ça je ne sais pas
mais enfin en tout cas une plus grande
autonomie dit donc que sean que les pays
les régions l'union européenne se
pensent davantage en termes d'éco
système est un écosystème et bien ça
passe notamment par le fait de d'avoir
d'être autonome en matière
d'approvisionnement en médicaments en
masques etc enfin je veux dire ça à mon
avis ça fait partie des leçons qu'on
peut et conduire de cette crise
justement est ce qu est ce que ça va
changer beaucoup de choses dans nos
mentalités dont ils ne voient là
l'occasion peut-être de voir la vie ce
que je ce que j'espère c'est peut-être
mettre des des valeurs qu'on voit
aujourd'hui des valeurs de courage
notamment de à des caissières des
infirmiers des médecins de toutes les
personnes qui arrivent à nous faire
vivre comme on peut en ce moment sa
période de confinement qui sont des
petits métiers qui étaient totalement
pas très valorisé et il faudra peut-être
réfléchir sur sur la valorisation de
tous ces mythes il n'y a pas que ce soit
possible alors les professeurs tarde
donc ça va falloir y réfléchir aussi sur
toutes ces valeurs et l'orientation de
notre société
justement jean baptiste des personnes
prennent des idéaux du club oui oui moi
c'est cet hôtel sur le l'impact est que
cette crise va avoir sur la perception
que les défauts leurs gouvernants
généralement en tout cas dans les
démocraties modernes
on croit que des taputu on apprend tout
le we effectivement si l'on trompe
olympique et crédible il est à craindre
que à la suite de cette crise une
défiance extrême à l'endroit de
gouvernance en alors
m patton parce que précisément le
prévisible c'est ce qui va se passer
dans le croiseur et j'espère qu'en tout
cas les majorités la mesure est le
report sans frais par les gouvernants
même si effectivement on ne sait pas non
plus de leur donner raison sur tout ce
qu'ils font et incontrôlée est
nécessaire mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi c'est quelque chose de tellement
fait pas aussi à actu et accepter que
l'on ne peut pas trouver prise et je
pense que malheureusement l'espèce
humaine a la mémoire très courte et
c'est un historien israélien qu'il a
bien décrit c'est le valais voilà
ravelli qui explique également la durée
de vie d'un homme est assez courte et
que l'enseignement des générations fait
que l'on oublie ce qui s'est passé
finalement il n'ya pas très longtemps et
qu'aujourd'hui a quasiment plus de
survivants de la grippe espagnole par
exemple et je pense qu'au contraire ça
va rien changer je pense qu'on va à la
fin retrouver nos vieux réflexes nos
vieux archaïsme et j'espère c'est un
voeu que j'espère qu'on ira quelques
conclusions sur l'écologie sur une
manière différente de percevoir les
choses d'uniquement sondés parce que
c'est magnifique mais j'ai bien peur
justement qu'on revienne à des besoins
primaires et qu'une fois qu'on sera d
eau fine et on revient à nos vieux
réflexes carl minault alors dû juste
pour revenir rapidement sur les parts
sur l'état providence la jeu en
thaïlande c'est quelque chose qui est
assez absents et il faudra que quand on
est riche
si les petits palets des entreprises et
donc illégales pour les individus ce
sont des gens qui ont qui sont partis et
qui n'avait qui n'étaient pas couverts
et évidemment ça prend quand on est
expatrié encore plus d'ampleur de se
rendre compte de la chance qu'on a
d'être en france et de bénéficier de
tout de toutes ses dettes et de tout de
tout ce support au niveau des individus
et on en fait encore plus conscience
profonde et néerlandais tim sale et
distant c'est pour répondre à votre
question sur l'évolution du monde moi je
pense que on l'a quand même observé une
accélération de du rééquilibrage
économique entre l'asie et le monde
occidental les fonds de protéger les
les pays occidentaux se sont fermées ils
sont avoir un impact économique qui
risque à mon sens mais je ne sers tu
bien sûr d'être plus important que les
pays d'asie comme la chine qu'il aurait
démarré beaucoup plus vite avec un peut
être un souci humain moins important
mais qui du coup vont encore à craquer
voire peut-être creuser l'écart sur
certains domaines des produits
industriels et c'est bien moi je suis
assez optimiste sur les coudes
économiquement suis un peu de la vie de
stéphane c'est très difficile de prévoir
après l'isi on sait pas ce qui va se
passer
karl a sûrement raison dans art
équilibrage peut-être effectivement il
faut beaucoup de choses soient
relocalisés peut-être des choses
absolument vital comme les médicaments
et des tonnes de choses mais en tout cas
humainement l'absolu je pense que
beaucoup de gens vont découvrir par ont
découvert que l'on pouvait peut-être un
peu moins circle et qu'on peut peut-être
consommer différemment on pouvait
apprécier un certain silence parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a demandé si le silence
dans les villes lorca qui est
quelquefois un peu glace en mai mais
maitient même temps fait du bien on re
découvre ce sens être troubat bacou
numéro découle le chant des oiseaux en
pleine ville donc donc ça c'est plutôt
sympathique
donc voilà ça repartira bien évidemment
parce que parce qu'il faut que ça
reparte mais mais peut-être que
certaines personnes ont pris conscience
de 2,2 de certaines règles
et là je rejoins aussi florence c'est
que effectivement il ya des gens qu'on
avait peut-être tendance non pas méprisé
mais mais mais a oublié un peu beaucoup
de métiers indispensables qui vont de
l'éboueur et qui font leur boulot qui se
plaignent pas et qui le font très bien
qui n'exercent pas leur droit de retrait
tout bout de champ et qu'il faut le job
et size d'aller vous êtes la plus jeune
d'entre nous dans thenergo est ce que
est ce que vous dites que le monde qui
vient d'être monde ici je ne sais pas si
évidemment on sait que ça va être
difficile mais bien au delà de cette
crise avec tous les enjeux
environnementaux et l'urgence climatique
qui va se poser c'est prochaines années
je pense beaucoup plus rapidement que ce
qu'on imagine
en revanche je suis assez optimiste sur
le fait que cette crise pour rebondir
sur les propos de karl
cette crise nous permet vu qu'elle est
mondial de mettre en regard des sociétés
qui sont qui sont assez similaires au
nôtre en terme de développement et
notamment de prendre conscience de la
chance qu'on a par rapport à ce système
de santé je pense notamment aux états
unis qui ce qui est un pays développé un
état développé comme le nôtre le monde a
fait un article sur le très lourd tribut
payé par les afro américains avaient crû
de cette crise et c'est dramatique de
dire que voilà une des populations
encore aujourd'hui dans les états
développés meurent par manque d'accès
aux soins et je pense que ça c'est une
bonne leçon à retenir de sa crise et
j'espère que les français nous prendrons
conscience de ça de ce qu'il peut se
passer en afrique qu'il faut évidemment
aller vite merci infiniment à tous merci
merci charlène des dinars claire et jean
baptiste duclair merci calvino bercy
dans chaque salle garbino alors d'israël
votre livre s'appelle le sicilien et
c'est aux éditions bien joué a dit non
nous avons l'éditeur qu'ils en savent la
jolie merci beaucoup stéphane mon sens
c'est une belle bibliothèque c'est du
faux il faut c'est du papier peint en
scène
merci beaucoup mais quelle mon voisin
merci beaucoup
et merci beaucoup regalber dos je
rappelle le notre titre nous de votre
livre pardon nous ne nous le marin sans
mémoire
eh ben je vous propose qu'on se retrouve
assez vite comme ça pour discuter de
l'actualité ça sera mon prochain par
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi on se
parle confiné et à très vite
[Musique]